une file d'attente encore une fois
devant ce bureau de la Société
d'assurance automobile du Québec et des
citoyens mécontents
j'ai réussi à me libérer mais le
prochain rendez-vous je pouvais avoir
c'est début septembre moi généralement
je paye par internet mais ça
fonctionnait pas hier toute la nuit je
voulais en fait juste payer ma sœur
Dieu est venu ici pour perdre 3 heures
de ma journée c'est ça la plateforme ça
clique Continue de connaître des ratés
plus de trois mois après son lancement
malgré la promesse de la Société de
l'assurance automobile du Québec de
retour à la normale en mai l'échéance
est maintenant reporté à la mi ou le
ministre des Transports demande de
nouveau aux citoyens de faire preuve de
patience je sais qu'il y a des délais
que ça peut être long la prise de
rendez-vous pour certains endroits c'est
quelques semaines mais avec les les
arrêter qu'on a qu'on a signé ça fait en
sorte que normalement vous ne serez pas
pénalisé bien que je sois consciente que
c'est très désagréable avec ces
problèmes de portail numérique à la SAQ
le chef intérimaire du Parti libéral du
Québec se dit lui maintenant inquiet
pour les prochains changements
informatiques à venir au sein du
gouvernement on voit que c'est un diasto
à la Société d'assurance automobile du
Québec et imaginez-vous donc c'est qu'il
va avoir de la transformation numérique
en santé et au ministère du Revenu ça
c'est très très inquiétant encore une
fois des maux de tête pour de nombreuses
automobilistes qui doivent prendre un
rendez-vous en ligne pour une prise de
photo par exemple
et de son côté la SAC n'a pas répondu à
nos nombreuses demandes d'entrevue pour
tenter de clarifier cette situation
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada
Montréal